the democratic party is in real trouble
because they are not sure which way to
turn
and if they listen to msnbc they're
going to turn in the radical direction
so first off let me just say there is
nothing quite as joyous in life as
watching media figures react to
republicans winning races
nothing quite as joyous so last night on
cnn we'll start with cnn last night on
cnn
john king was announcing the results in
virginia to jake tapper and uh jake
tapper is
all the media writ large right here this
is this is
this reaction is is what the media
thought last night
just about everywhere terry mcauliffe is
underperforming joe biden so you say
okay that's not fair that's a
presidential year is he underperforming
ralph northam i began the night saying
he can ralph northern won by eight nine
points the incumbent democratically the
incumbent governor so terry mcauliffe
can underperform him as long as he
doesn't underperform him by a ton this
is your live vote right now
where are there counties where mcauliffe
is underperforming northern by more than
oh my god by more than 10 points he is
underperforming
[Laughter]
meanwhile larry sabato who declared
pretty much that everybody who votes in
favor of the republicans is a white
supremacist because they've been taken
in and duped by the evil critical race
theory narrative uh he was like yeah i'm
hearing from the call of campaign it's
just a bloodbath again there's nothing
more fun for republicans than turning on
msnbc on a bad night for democrats
i'm not going to call it a blowout
because we don't have the final uh final
numbers but i will tell you somebody in
high up in the mcaulis camp who was
there with mcauliffe
put it this way to me about an hour ago
it's a bloodbath
and so far everything we've seen pretty
much falls along that line and while we
don't have complete figures anything
close to complete figures for the house
of delegates you can guess based on what
i've just said
yeah man so it got it got so good at
msnbc
watching watching msnbc was like
watching several hours of just the last
scene of raiders of the lost ark right
just when they opened the ark and
suddenly
thoughts
face just melts off right or or when
bella just it's just them screaming as
the ark is open just screaming until
their heads explode it's just the last
it's just outtakes from the last scene
of raiders of the lost ark it's just
spectacular so last night msnbc host
remember terry mccullough lost this race
because he decided that a great campaign
strategy was to say that if you're
worried about your child's education
it's because you're a homophobe or if
you're worried about critical race
theory in schools it's because you're a
racist or if you're against the american
federation of teachers it's because you
were some sort of horrible bigot and
school boards needed to be in charge of
your children not you this was terry
mcauliffe's entire campaign and so the
the idiots over at msnbc
apparently their strategy is to just
keep stopping that chicken they're just
going to keep stopping it
so
so last night msnbc msnbc host
decided it's not us that are wrong it's
the children who are wrong
here they were decrying dangerous racist
republicans now i just want to point
something out
these racist republicans elected last
night a lieutenant governor in virginia
named winsome sears she's a marine
veteran she also happens to be black
okay so they elected a a black woman as
the lieutenant governor because they are
vicious white supremacists they also
elected an attorney general of virginia
who is um a cuban american
to replace a white guy by the way the
current incumbent ag is is a white guy
and they elected glenn youngkin to
replace a current democratic incumbent
who was in a yearbook wearing either
blackface or a kkk outfit we still don't
know which
yes it's the republicans who are the
white supremacist clearly there's msnbc
going with that narrative
the question for democrats is going to
be you almost rome spelled again do you
go on the campaign show with the
republican party you know you've got
that they lie that they wander the trump
racism in in in fleece that they have a
propaganda network that reaches more
people than any candidate's ads in any
state reduction do you adjust with this
new propaganda disinformation barely
veiled dog whistle race stuff or do you
keep trying to fight on you know policy
oh yeah that cause that was the race the
race was democrats trying to talk policy
and republicans doing veiled dog
whistles except the critical race theory
is taught in the schools and they tried
to play this gaslighting game for months
on end
you would point out that kids were being
taught racial essentialism in schools
they would be being taught that america
is replete with white privilege that it
is inherent in every major institution
they're being taught 1619 project
garbage in the schools and the entire
take from the democratic party is we're
not even teaching critical race theory
we don't even know what critical race
theory is and then when you say okay
fine so what if we just get rid of it
like no no it's super important that
your kids learn critical race theory
because otherwise they won't be learning
real history
right the gas lighting was very strong
and parents were like you know what you
can just go
yourself like we are not interested in
being told that we are that we are fools
for for wanting to know what our kids
are being taught in school see one of
the things that happened with zoom
school last year is the parents finally
got to see what their kids were being
taught in school and they weren't super
happy about it that is for sure
meanwhile on msnbc the meltdown
continued steve kornacki trying to
inform the msnbc panel so the people who
hosted this were nicole wallace who's a
hack and joy reid who's the biggest hack
on television and rachel mata who was
the moderate on the panel it says steve
kornacki trying to deliver the news
that um democrats were just getting
walloped in virginia and that new jersey
was closed
you had to feel a little bit for steve
kornacki because he was basically like
the he's he was sort of like the persian
messenger in 300 who has to deliver the
news to leonidas that the hordes are
coming right
it's just it's gonna go super poorly
right like steve kornacki is like i beg
of you my liege i i it's not me i didn't
vote this way i'm not gonna but i just i
hate to bring you this news like he had
a feel for kornacki right because he's
just he's just trying to bring them the
stats and everybody on msnbc is like
behead him why is gornacky bringing
steve kornack he's like i'm just the
messenger guys like yes well here we
shoot the messenger okay so you can see
kornacki's expression he's like oh god
this job ah some nights hey so here's
rachel maddow complaining that um fox
kept talking about critical race theory
how could they talk about critical race
theory it's not like it was a major
issue for people what their kids were
being taught in schools
here's rachel maddow doing this routine
to have the fox news channel our friends
at the fox news channel
building their programming particularly
the prime time programming around this
four months they're building a campaign
platform for conservative candidates to
run on it everywhere even though it's
not actually anywhere even though it's
not a real thing i mean that there's
there's nothing you could pay for in any
campaign that would equal the kind of
free help you'd get from that sort of
conservative media just fire hose on the
issue
okay i love that you gotta love the lack
of awareness from rachel maddow i mean
there's nothing like like free media
coverage of an issue that republicans
care about yes rachel i'm sure that's
what happened in virginia what happened
in virginia for sure is that republican
media are just so dominant they're just
so powerful all the time republican
media i mean what it's not like there's
a network
that spends all day every day pushing a
democratic agenda it's not like every
host on a network pushes that agenda in
the most radical possible do you own a
mirror people you're on msnbc
and you're saying oh man look at those
republicans fire hosing republican
issues i mean just just terrible look at
fox and and all these conservative media
okay i'm just going to name a few
networks just off the top of my head
here msnbc cnn abc
cbs nbc
the new york times the washington post
right now we're not getting that it's
now our newspapers new york times
washington post l.a times chicago
tribune
every major outlet
every major outlet with the exception of
essentially the wall street journal and
fox news
every legacy media outlet supports the
democrats and they're like i can't
believe this fox news these fox news
people did ever occur to them that maybe
the reason people watch fox news is
because you guys won't report
again i refer you over to daily wire get
a subscription because luke rosiak did
the reporting these jokers wouldn't do
our investigative journalist lugrozak
did a yeoman's work in loudoun county
and you should support that work because
your entire journalism population won't
do any of that work instead they will
just repeat that remember the entire
luke rosiac story about scott smith who
is the parent
who was wrestled to the ground and
called the domestic terrorist because he
was angry that the school board had said
that no one had been raped in a bathroom
and he knew that his daughter had
remember the entire media just ran with
the story that he was a domestic
terrorist it took lou groziac to uncover
the fact that he was actually just a
rightly pissed off parent
hey but again this is the theme over at
msnbc just keep stuck in that chicken
man stupid until it's not frozen anymore
here's see here is nicole wallace again
saying critical race theory is fake it's
all fake it's all in your imagination
what is happening in sort of republican
america it's not just critical race
theory it's it's saying you know fraud
happened their people believed there was
fraud so they're fixing it so republican
voters see republicans never mind that
it's fake critical race theory isn't
taught it means something different to
voters they think it is so republicans
are fixing it junk is going to ban it
and some of it is just a question for
democrats now do you adjust to a terrain
that is not fair that is not just that
it's all fact-based but that this
tonight looks like it advantages
republican
it's unreal it's unreal they're just
going to keep denying it they're just
going to keep denying and then they'll
tell you it's super important to follow
it
now here's joy reid who's the worst of
the bunch over there joy reid is just
the fact that she's on a nightly show is
such an unbelievable joke because i'm
not sure that she said a correct thing
in several years at this point
so she says that when you say education
in virginia what you really mean
is white parents don't like teaching
about race
when white people say education what
they really mean is white supremacy
keep on going with this really like i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna sit back here
you guys do your thing in fact
i would love to nominate if i if i had
the power i would nominate joy reid to
be head of the dnc she should be they
should just follow her strategy just
keep calling everything you don't like
white supremacy see how that works out
for you here is joy reid
and the exit poll showed that
which was interesting that the
coronavirus or the virus it was a very
low importance to many voters
it was education right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race and i mean
unfortunately
race is just the most palpable tool in
the tool kit used to be of the
democratic party back in the day when
they were dixiecrats and now of the
republican party it just is powerful
okay it was glenn it was it was glenn
young being attacked by tara mcauliffe
as a racist who was it was mcauliffe
making race the issue it was that old
white guy telling you that all the
republicans were racist that was the
campaign
republicans were just saying we don't
want our kids taught that some people
are worse because of their race and it
was democrats saying if you don't teach
that you won't teach history and you're
a racist
joy reid accusing others of playing the
race card
i mean honest to god it's like o.j
simpson accusing you of murder like
that's not
there's something wrong
here joy reid has several decks of cards
except it's like a magic deck the only
card in the deck is the race card that
is the only card in all of her myriad
decks there are no kings there are no
tens there are no eights it's just the
race card that's all and she does it
every night on her show for every issue
and then she's like these republicans
they're constantly playing the race card
can you believe it
and then you wonder why we went crazy
and then you wonder why everybody went
out and voted against the democrats keep
on going guys keep on going cnn's van
jones did some of the same stuff he was
saying well you know glenn younkin he's
just the delta variant trump delta
varying trump because you see trump is
like a disease and glen youngkin is like
a worse more virulent form of the
disease this is not going to work
because glenn young can number one is
not trump and number two people do not
see basic conservatism as a disease
here's dan jones
when this election is over in virginia
we will know
have we seen the emergence of the delta
variant of trumpism
the delta variant of trumpism in other
words junkin uh same disease but spreads
a lot faster it can get a lot more
places the suburbs if they fall to him
you know that's implying that yeah that
junkin is more dangerous than what is it
well
no no more easy to spread okay because
more easier to spread because if you if
you look at what he's doing he is
playing footsie with the worst of trump
isn't
is he really come on get washably summed
up this entire line of attack in a tweet
last night former cnn commentator
whiteness remains undefeated let's wait
and see who these white suburban voters
went for tonight in virginia any guesses
whiteness remains undefeated again first
black female lieutenant governor in
virginia first hispanic ag in virginia
whiteness remains undefeated weird
because uh nine months ago
joe biden won that state by ten points
nine months ago so yeah man whiteness
remains undefeated that's a solid tape
keep going with that really just keep
going
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe